I have a quote from another actor this
time and it is the further you get away
from yourself the more challenging it is
not to be in your comfort zone is great
fun and this is from none other than
Benedict Cumberbatch so do you like play
roles that are sort of your polar
opposite or maybe you're more of a
chameleon you can be many things many
days and that's okay because that's all
part of it yeah yeah I have been lucky
that I can be a chameleon I think I'm
more of a character actor so I don't
really fit I don't think into any
category and it is a challenge to play
somebody that's farthest away from you
and sometimes most of the time when you
get those sides or you get that audition
you're running from it feel like I've
that's not I can't do that that's not
that's not for me and they're never
going to pick me they're never going to
choose me and then you find a way to do
it you go in and you show them something
that they didn't think about and then
you end up getting that's happened a lot
of the times and then it it does
challenge you to go deeper and to get in
the mind of somebody else and I love
playing somebody that's so completely
opposite of me but there's always a
little part of you I think it every
character that you portray because you
have to start from somewhere you have to
start from you you have to start from
your own experiences and then kind of go
from there so let's take that if you
let's suppose you get a callback for
something that you're already may be
nervous about but of course they love
you would you then go and maybe start
researching people of that type or it
would it keep in your mind when you see
someone let's say the grocery store
someone to that what's your process um
my process usually is honestly I just
once you read an audition you just kind
of get this sort of energy that comes
from reading the lines and and and then
I kind of I don't even know what happens
I don't even think you can sort of play
a a word on it just you get this sort of
like okay that's how I'm going to do it
and it might be wrong but you make a
choice and then you go in there and
hopefully they like a choice and then
sometimes you go in there and they're
like no we want to see it a completely
different way and then you have to sort
of take direction on a dime because
that's also part of the process I think
they want to see you the characters as
the character but they also want to see
how well you can take direction and
instant because that's what it's like on
set you have to be able to meld yourself
you know and take direction and go a
different way if it's not working
you